[Music]
hi guys we're finally back from anyway
describe in words how how the tool was
is to experience like from from the
fundamental standpoint it was one of the
best experiences I've had since I
started doing YouTube just being able to
go from city to city you'd be able to
see you guys in this really warm and
inviting setting and also pushed
ourselves me a Tyler wake Bob and also
animated Catherine II and everyone else
who was a part of the team that made it
possible just seeing everyone push them
so so hard to make something special and
the response from the fans was beyond it
and we'd ever hoped for we actually
recorded every
a little performance we have for
recording with us on stage and audience
reactions from everybody I don't think
we're gonna put out a full video but
what we will do probably is send out a
bunch of highlights between me and all
my friends they will give you snippets
of it then when we bring it back in the
fall it'll be even bigger and better
than was this time and no videos have
been sporadic since then but that's one
because of the amount of work that we
had to do well over there I had
anticipated to be able to film in a vlog
while I was out there but that just
didn't happen because there was so much
and you can expect highlights to come
out from that over the next couple of
weeks or so
must be a problem it's some of the
dancing bits the opening the ending and
definitely some of the Q&A because there
was some really heartfelt warming
moments that I really the last just it
was something really special because
after all this work got done we all took
turns it's a safe closing statements and
I was holding it together
everyone was pretty much on the verge of
tears until Bob decided to open his
mouth and he had the gall to like to
thank me personally and I just like I
had flashback straight to the twenty
thousand subscriber fan video which I
still go back and I still look back at
that and I still think about like the
words that they they all said to me and
especially Bob no no I don't know why it
is presently Bob like Bob is like one of
the most sarcastic people I know but it
makes the moments when he's really
sincere all that more special and just
like
and it's something I'll never forget
you guys haven't seated because we
haven't recorded so I'll put that out of
the next step but weak yourself but just
wanna say thank you guys so much for the
patient's videos we'll be back on
schedule got some cute videos I probably
posted after this but I got a cute video
of my mom got a new puppy by the name of
Belle tell it's the cutest puppy I've
ever seen I haven't met Belle in person
yet but a good a little of the cheapest
you're a fool forgive you for stepping
on my balls I'm bursting at the seams to
be able to make this cool thing and then
go on tour again thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always we will
see you next video bye bye say bye to
them give up hold all day bye bye bye
bye bye